bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte ce
n'est pas tous les jours qu'un nouveau
parc national est créé aujourd'hui on
vous emmène dans les coulisses du parc
dopé mi corps qui a été inauguré en juin
dernier au témiscamingue 18 octobre 2018
l'automne est bien installé sur le
témiscamingue
sous nos yeux le chantier du pack d'eau
pénicaud le dernier né des parcs
nationaux du québec
[Musique]
le temps presse pour avancer au maximum
les travaux avant que la neige ne
recouvre la région
on voit que ça aboutit on voit comme le
lait senti qu'ils se construisent on
voit les bâtiments qui s'érigent on
l'aurait ce parc lors on y pense mais là
on le voit qui se renforce et très très
basse à l'inauguration officielle du
parc est prévue le 21 juin 2019 et il
reste encore beaucoup à faire
déjà à l'été 2010 8,1 premier secteur du
parc a été ouvert à la population
mais depuis les problèmes n'ont cessé de
s'accumuler
le temps froid et un feu de forêt ont
ralenti considérablement les travaux il
y avait les avions citernes carroza
secteur
vainqueur au final avec justement
beaucoup beaucoup de pression sont nos
équipes ont leur rendu mais c'est
certain qu'on n'a pas le choix on a pris
un peu de retard on fait avec marc
nature fac on travaillait
nous sommes retournés au parc national
dopé mika début juin 2019
après la pause hivernale c'est la
frénésie sur le chantier
[Musique]
l'ouverture arrive à grands pas il reste
à peine une quinzaine de jours pour tout
complété
[Musique]
mais rien n'est joué d'avancé
au printemps les fortes pluies qui se
sont abattues sur le québec ont fait
très mal
ici aussi on a eu des conditions du
jamais vu au niveau de la rivière kipawa
donc des babys extrêmement élevés qui
ont eu pour effet d'en porter notre lien
pour le secteur kipawa donc le pont
était complètement arrachée
donc c'est un pont qui avait 27 m donc
un pas majeur qui se refait pas en
criant ciseau tout un secteur du parc
déjà prête à recevoir les visiteurs est
désormais inaccessible
on s'entend que ça a été ça a été un
coup à toute l'équipe mais on se
retrousse les manches puis on va
continuer on n'est pas dans des milieux
contrôler tout ça donc ça fait partie du
risque et loeb un hall vie
[Musique]
le 12 juin dont confirmé le 12 août à
conques les femmes stabilisation des
talus opaques se passait mal
c'est juste pour plus d'un milliard e et
le directeur du parc
c'est lui qui coordonne les travaux
réalisés par des entrepreneurs privés et
les employés de la société des
établissements de plein air du québec
là c'est pas parce qu'on partage tous
par esprit de résilience là on était
très engagé dans le processus
d'aménagement du parc
c'est énormément de travail tout le
monde est investie fait qu'en qui
arrivent des difficultés c'est certain
qu'on veut pas abandonner l'on veut
juste les surmonter puis arrivé à la
destination le nouveau parc national
d'optique en couvre un territoire de 252
km carrés divisé en trois secteurs
distincts celui du lac white lapointe au
penny camp et la rivière kipawa avec sa
chute majestueuse
ici on se trouve à la jonction des
domaines feuillus et boréal les pères
rouge et blanc ils sont impressionnants
pour concevoir ce parc et mettre en
valeur ses attraits la sépaq a utilisé
les derniers moyens technologiques à sa
disposition
par exemple grâce à la télédétection par
laser
on a pu relever la topographie du
terrain au mètre près
[Musique]
ça nous a procuré un outil de haute
précision pour planifier les futurs
aménagements que ce soit des sentiers ou
même les bâtiments les campings c'est
tout au long du processus d'aménagement
a été ouvert au centre de notre
planification
ensuite un autre outil qu'on a utilisé
de façon plus ponctuelle c'est le drone
qui nous permet aussi encore là d'aller
chercher de l'imagerie dans un secteur
difficilement accessible et de nous
donner une vision d'ensemble donc là
dans l'aménagement des sentiers entre
autres le site un outil qu'on a utilisé
et justement dans les sentiers
le travail se poursuit sans relâche et
légaux soit en train de faire une belle
job ils avancent puis pour la
finalisation pour avoir une idée quand
on cherche non roche légaux love viser
vraiment le plat les plus grosses roches
possible plus son titre après dix mille
passages cc petite lotus déstabilise
avec l'expérience acquise au fil des
années la sépaq a aussi modifié sa façon
de construire les sentiers pour faire un
minimum de dommages beaucoup plus de
travaux sont désormais réalisées à la
main anciennement on a là avec la
machinerie on ouvrait le sentier envoyé
un très bon est-ce qu'on a des
contraintes ou quoi que ce soit ce plu
quand m là cet aspect là et à l'avant
scène comme vous êtes plutôt la
conservation trim et ensuite de son
expérience aux clients on va la
valoriser notre contexte là mais tout en
maintenant des des milieux le plein
impact possible les tracés des sentiers
ont donc été conçus pour ne pas déranger
les faucons pèlerins sur leurs sites de
nidification ou encore pour protéger des
plantes rares comme le pire aux sports à
fleurs d'andromède pour mais aussi plus
d'énergie pour assurer un excellent
drainage lorsque les sentiers sont boue
et les randonneurs sortent souvent du
tracé et endommagent la flore
environnante
on cherche à garder les gens sur le
sentier est vraiment l'écoulement comme
on voit les canaux et tout ça sorte
l'eau donc nos personnes restent
au bon endroit on a des endroits par
exemple dans le réseau où cette
technique là on pas nécessairement été
mis de l'avant et l'on doit reprendre
ses sections de sentir ton
progressivement les sentiers du réseau
de la sépaq son remodifier plus souvent
ses associés à des problématiques de
drainage le secteur principal du parc
c'est la pointe au bény quand c'est là
qu'on a construit le centre de services
[Musique]
tout autour on retrouve une grande
quantité de bâtiments à forte valeur
patrimoniale
des témoins de l'époque où ce site
accueillait de nombreux voyageurs et
travailleurs venus profiter de l'essor
de l'industrie forestière dans la région
ces vestiges du 19e siècle ont donné du
fil à retordre à la sépaq qui n'a pas
l'habitude de composer avec ce type
d'engin on a un déficit qu'on voulait
préserver les bâtiments historiques
on venait restauré pour les rendre
accessible le plus possible au public
c'est pas toujours facile parce qu'on en
a qui était très détérioré voire même
presque disparu donc on recrée en eux un
vieux bâtiment pour le rendre pour le
mettre en valeur le public plus en
profite et puis qu'on puisse expliquer
ce pan d'histoire le conte et au
témiscamingue dans notre région mais
c'était sans compter sur le martinet
ramoneur une espèce menacée qui a élu
domicile dans les cheminées de
l'ancienne auberge au doigt regardez
bien on voit justement un de ces oiseaux
pénétrer tête première dans une cheminée
durant l'entrevue
sa présence pose tout un casse tête pour
la restauration du bâtiment parce que
les ouvriers ne peuvent pas travailler
durant la période de nidification
donc là on doit concilier une
restauration de bâtiments
si on ne restaure pas le bâtiment va
tomber mais de l'autre côté on a une
espèce qu'on veut maintenir et ensuite
ce qu'on veut valoriser et cohabiter
avec l'usagé par contre tout un défi de
conservation l'occupation du parc
remonte à bien avant l'époque du
flottage du bois depuis des milliers
d'années
ce territoire est habité par les
anishnabe mieux connu sous le nom d'al
gore
avant et pendant les travaux des
archéologues ont ratissé le territoire à
la recherche d'artefacts témoin de leur
histoire on a trouvé plusieurs choses
notamment dans les surprises qu'on a eu
on a trouvé un biface donc une sorte de
dh qui auraient été associés justement
la présence anishnabe la présence
autochtone dont qui pourrait dater de
plusieurs milliers d'amis on est comme
un éléphant dans un magasin de
porcelaine
on omet les pieds quand on fait toujours
attention où l'on met les pieds pour
justement avoir le minimum d'impact les
anishnabe sont toujours là aujourd'hui
et ils ont eu leur mot à dire dans la
création du parc national dopé ni quand
la sépaq et les représentants des
premières nations du québec et de wolf
lake ont décidé de travailler main dans
la main
[Musique]
il ya eu pas mal de défis au début le
principal c'est celui qui nous vient du
passé et qui est toujours d'actualité
c'est que nous n'avons jamais cédé notre
territoire algonquin à la couronne au
canada à la province de québec
donc avec la venue du parc qui allait
prendre un peu de notre territoire
c'était un sujet délicat cela étant dit
je crois que nous voyons les
perspectives d'avenir et les avantages
qui pourraient découler du fait que le
parc se trouve dans notre cour arrière
pour le directeur du parc
il n'était pas question de se présenter
auprès des premières nations avec un
projet déjà ficelé le respect et
l'ouverture ont été au coeur du
processus de consultation
je pense que c'est une question
d'authenticité l'objectif c'est souvent
de vouloir réaliser des projets avec les
communautés autochtones
mais avant de réaliser des projets il
faut apprendre à se connaître
donc le temps qu'ils ont investi à
développer une relation avec les gens
apprennent à se connaître à bien
comprendre
leur vision de développement puis leur
intérêt aussi
si on le fait en amont puis on le fait
comme il faut après ça on est capable de
parler d'enjeux lorsqu'ils surviennent
puis leur relation de confiance et des
jolis sauts fortes sommes
wii play open john sweeney first
résultats pour la nouvelle génération de
leaders anishnabe le parc est devenu un
allié et non un adversaire le parquet
les premières nations nous partageons
plusieurs valeurs protéger
l'environnement les animaux les arbres
et l'eau alors oui le parc empêchera les
activités minières et l'augmentation des
coupes forestières dans ce secteur
spécifique ce qui est sans aucun doute
un avantage pour nous à cela s'ajoutent
toutes les possibilités qui s'offre à
nous avec les milliers de personnes qui
viendront visiter le parc chaque été
nous développerons notre propre
infrastructure touristique et nous
pourrons vraiment agir de façon
complémentaire et faire de cet endroit
la place qu'il faut venir visiter la
sépaq a aussi mis en place un programme
de stages qui a permis à plusieurs
anishnabe de trouver un emploi dans
l'équipe du parc des bûcherons et des
bâtisseurs de sentiers ont aussi été
embauchée je pense que la collaboration
entre les communautés autochtones et le
parc est très important parce que ça
reconnaît que les algonquins était ici
depuis longtemps et puis c'est toujours
considéré comme un territoire algonquine
ça allait créer un espace où que les
deux peuples peuvent travailler ensemble
ça c'est très important pour tout le
monde
[Musique]
pendant ce temps la course contre la
montre se poursuit
c'est pas tous les jours qu'un parc
national qui se créent et participé à la
création de bijoux qui vont pouvoir être
utilisé par maintes et maintes
génération l'espère c'est quelque chose
d'exceptionnel
c'est une chance d'une vie
on est confiant on est content mais on
sent aussi dans l'équipe le l'émotion
monte je pense qu'elle 21 joueurs ont vu
quelque chose de vraiment spécial
[Musique]
je